committee
and I want to thank the members for
um
permitting this
off-time meeting I had a request
originally from a representative from
Windham saying there would be a benefit
to the town if we could meet earlier and
uh
thank you all for making that happen so
yes Senator Pro
I do have to leave here by about 9 35 9
40 at the latest we'll be wrapped up and
down the road thank you thank you
all right so we will open up I will as
everyone had the minutes received in
your package
are there any
um need for Corrections or emissions
seeing none accept a
motion to accept the minutes I'll second
that okay
all those in favor signify by saying aye
aye
we have no old business
new business one two three
four four items before us we will start
with lrcp
23012 Department of Transport
Transportation requests authorization to
sell 1.73 plus a minus acre parcel of
state-owned land located on the
Northerly side of Enterprise Drive town
of Windham directly to AJ
latazzo professional
letizio professional Center LLC for 75
000 which includes 1100 administrative
fee subject to the conditions the
specifications in the request dated
March 30th 2023.
sir thank you Mr chairman I'm Steve
Labonte I'm the administrator of the
Bureau of right-of-way with the New
Hampshire Department of Transportation
Department request authorization to cell
1.73 acre parcel of state-owned land
located on the Northerly side of
Enterprise Drive in the town of Windham
Direct
[Music]
directly to the AJ letizio Professional
Center for 75 000 including the 1100
administrative fee the parcel is a
portion of a much larger uh acquisition
that was acquired back in 2007 from
George G Dinsmore Trustee of the George
G Dinsmore revocable trust the
department at that time for the 104
Acres paid 4 million six hundred and
thirty thousand and it was uh conveyed
via warranty deed through a negotiated
settlement it was part of a much larger
uh part of a lawsuit
[Music]
um
so this the this portion of that 104
Acres was originally
15 acres and this is just one 1.73
Acres of that 15 Acres so it was four
Parcels together on Enterprise Drive
which uh
was the 15 Acres the parcel will be
conveyed with the following conditions
the grantee shall be responsible for all
local and state land use permits
precedent to uh closing access to the
parcel will be through the abutting
parcels the state is retaining All
rights of access from Enterprise Drive
any future in
uh future improvements will be in celery
use only and uh the conveyance will
include a reversionary clause
should any of these conditions be
breached a little bit more of a
background Mr letizio approached the
town in the state about a project he's
acquiring the property he's actually
going to donate half the parcel to the
town of Windham which abuts the Indian
Rock historical site and they're going
to develop kind of uh Outdoor Classroom
type setting to that
so in order to make this happen the
state has put such burdens on the
property that it can only be it it's
only got
contributory value to either a budding
parcel so there's no direct access they
can't it's not like you can turn around
and sell it
um
as an independent parcel to be developed
separately it can only be
um
used for that purpose so the parcel was
a praise to be as contributory value 73
900 plus the Eleven Hundred Dollar
administrative fee brings us to 75 000.
I'm happy to take any questions sure
questions from Miss salamante
if I could
I don't remember
transfers too often like this no not
non-buildable
um and I assume I'm not familiar with
the proper air price Drive is a limited
access road is it or it's just another
class 5 Highway okay so it's all right
no This was um
uh
yeah this is a very unique conveyance
um we got creative so that this project
could happen
thank you for that any further questions
seeing none is their emotion on
23012 I moved to approve
motion motion made and seconded
any further discussion
motions to accept uh
23012 if you are in favor signify by
saying aye
aye those opposed
the it is unanimous so would you take us
through request
23013 please
thank you Mr chairman
the department request approval to
dispose of 14 acres of state-owned land
with improvements located on f-185 Pine
Knoll Terrace in the town of Lisbon the
department will enter into a listing
agreement for a term of one year with uh
carrying guyampa Realtors listing price
for the parcel will be a hundred and
forty thousand
with the Department uh assessing an
administrative fee of eleven hundred
dollars
the department will seek to negotiate
within the committee's current policy
guidelines which is within 10 percent
downward
um the parcel was acquired in 1997 from
Sylvia G Kinney via warranty deed for 76
000 uh the parcel was acquired for the
bath Lisbon project which has since been
dissolved uh recently at the GNC meeting
on March 22nd 2023.
um we sought market analysis from the
approved the proof Realtors list
we received two two analysis and they
were at 129 000 and 147 733 dollars the
state appraisal was 129
000.
I'm happy to take questions thank you
are there any questions
seeing none pleasure of the uh
Commission
um okay
emotions been made uh and seconded any
further discussion
if you're in favor of the motion 23013
signified by saying I I those opposed
motion passes unanimously
and if we could on
23014 Department of Transportation
thank you Mr chairman the department
requests authorization to sell uh 0.44
Acres of a parcel of state-owned land
located on the Northerly side of 123 in
the town of New Ipswich the sale will be
direct to Prime roofing for 3 500 which
includes
the administrative fee uh 1100
administrative fee
the department received a request from
higher design
on behalf of the grantee to acquire a
portion of land located on the grantees
property or between the grantees
property and 100 foot
right-of-way the parcel request
requesting consists of surplus land as
well as a portion of the former layout
of New Hampshire Route 123 and 124 which
has been discontinued the parcel is a
portion of a 1.7 acre parcel acquired in
1958 to from Donald and Beatrice Packard
via warranty deed for 150 dollars
the parcel
um
the grantee will be required to have a
survey done for a perimeter boundary
line
depicting the limits of the right-of-way
which will meet standards to be
registered and to be recorded in the
registry of deeds grantee will be
responsible for all local and state land
use permits
um
this was appraised as contributory value
only because it's just an awkward shaped
parcel of land
and it it was valued at twenty four
hundred dollars which brings us with the
administrative fee to 3 500. I'm happy
to take any questions thank you are
there any questions Mr Lamonte
seeing none is there a motion on 23014
moved by Senator Pearl second by
second
second represent Mills
um any further discussion
seeing none if you're in favor of the
motion signify by saying aye aye
those opposed passes unanimously
thank you Mr Lamont appreciate your time
our next presentation is lrcp
by the Department of Transportation and
it's a railroad property
welcome to Public Works
is your pusher
button on there thank you thank you
thank you uh chairman my name is Lou
Barker from Dot's Bureau of rail and
Transit here to present to you a request
to renew
for leases
in this three in the city of Manchester
one in the town of Salem
advertising uh facilities that were put
on state railroad property
the interesting thing about this is I've
proposed using a consumer price index to
adjust the prices from a
lease agreements that were all approved
by this committee and for governor and
Council five years ago
if you have any questions I'd be glad to
discuss our procedure
questions for uh Mr Barker
yes
please
uh thank you Mr chair and uh thanks
Ransom it's kind of an inquiry just
interested what kind of rules are there
as far as what can be on the advertising
I assume is some type of a reg or does
it get reviewed by the state
actually that wouldn't necessarily be
reviewed by The Bureau um I know they
would have to go to the city of
Manchester and that's actually five
years ago that's who told us about these
facilities
no uh yeah we we definitely would uh
have the ability to terminate the lease
if they do something that's contrary to
uh State uh policies and appropriate uh
materials
follow-up representative Decker
uh no I still have the questions about
it but thank you okay
represent Mills okay
you know you're starting to be around a
while when you start seeing five-year
agreements come back up and you're
sitting here so
I um I I like the um I like your use of
the CPI there because I was trying to
figure out how we were and we're seeing
a little more Revenue I don't have a
question are there any further questions
okay seeing none
um
accept emotion on
I move approval Mr chairman all right
motion made seconded by Mills
um
are there any further questions
if you're in favor of the motion
23009 signify by saying aye
aye those opposed nay
um motion passes unanimously thank you
thank you sir
next items number five on the agenda
informational
2301 10 New Hampshire Council on
resources and development
um their minutes Chris was there
anything that you want to do uh Mr Shea
say anything on that
no I have no comments on you thank you
would that be the same on New Hampshire
Council on resource and development also
that's the same it's it's a review of
projects that are being asked to um
either released or or sold so the court
provides this additional information
okay thank you Mr chair
the last item of business is a day of
the next meeting uh previously scheduled
for May 26 at 9 30 to be held here in
this room and if there's conflicts
please let us know
any any other business to come before us
okay
where we thank you for being here today
um and
um I will adjourn um
motion made seconded by Cloutier all
those in favor signify by saying aye aye
those opposed motion to adjourn passage
unanimously thank you for your time